il ose important que vous oubliez sans
doute marque de dire c'est pas les jeux
olympiques ont soit la compétition c'est
l'institution comité interne olympique
lorsque en 2013 ils ont d'ailleurs 2013
lancé l'appel l'agenda 20 20
il ya eu deux révolutions a pas
aujourd'hui coubertin il ya eu la
révolution samaranch en 1981
le mouvement olympique les jeux
olympiques étaient totalement exsangues
ça m'arrange a dit je fais rentrer les
professionnels et le marketing ça a été
une inflation un
incroyable au point de l'argent de une
orgie de rentrées d'argent et tout ça ça
c'était la première à la première
évolution 80 et tous les effets que ça
use toutes les candidatures tous les
pays qui voulaient organiser les jeux la
deuxième révolution c'est celle de
thomas sba 2013 lorsqu'il a inventé la
jada 20 en dix ans les jeux olympiques
ne peut plus être cette petite
compétition qui dure 15 jours il faut
que ce soit totalement intégré dans la
politique nationale territoriale du pays
dont vous faites en sorte que
l'olympisme les jeux olympiques sim ici
ainsi je peux dire c'est un style dans
tous les éléments les monuments les
quartiers l'égard des transports et ça
c'est une véritable révolution
et marc permanent seul ouvrage de montre
bien que on n'a pas bien perçu en france
ont des a chic c'est très bien comme ça
ça rentre dans mon programme politique
et ainsi de suite mais les conséquences
sont énormes c'est qu'on aura olympique
et si je peux dire en bien ou en mal
avec une chance ou avec malédiction en
beaucoup moins beau ça chacun jugera à
l'arrivée mais c'est clair que c'est une
transformation radicale non seulement du
sport mais c'est aux régates de la ville
[Musique]